[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute gibt es eines
meiner lieblings torten ich bin ja ein
kleiner sneakers sucht die und deshalb
zeige ich euch heute die ultimative
sneakers torte mir war es vor allem
wichtig dass die torte nicht zu mächtig
ist und dass sie trotzdem aber die
typischen sneakers eigenschaften hat
nämlich schokolade das karamell und die
salzigen erdnüsse und jetzt zeige ich
euch alles was ihr für die leckere torte
benötigt das ist zum einen ein saftiger
schoko boden das video dazu verlinke ich
euch unten in die infobox und den habe
ich bereits in der hälfte durch geteilt
für die karamell schicht benötigen wir
schlag sahne zucker und gesalzene
erdnüsse
um unser karamell zuzubereiten geben wir
den zucker in eine beschichtete pfanne
und lassen das bei mittel hoher hitze
schmelzen
[Musik]
dieser prozess hat bei mir bis zu 15
minuten gedauert natürlich kommt es zu
hause bei euch auf euren herd an wie
lange das ganze zum karamellisieren
braucht und auch wenn sich stückchen
bilden und klümpchen verzweifelt nicht
gut einfach immer weiter und wartet bis
der zucker karamellisiert
[Musik]
sobald dann alle klümpchen verschwunden
sind und der zucker komplett
karamellisiert ist geben wir die
schlagsahne mit hinzu durch den
temperaturunterschied wird das ganze
jetzt einmal klumpen und dann rührt ihr
einfach ständig weiter auf mittlerer
stufe und das ganze löst sich auf und
verbindet sich zu einer einheitlichen
masse
[Musik]
nachdem dann alles noch einmal auf
gekocht wurde und die klümpchen
verschwunden sind schalten mit den herd
aus und geben die gesalzene erdnüsse mit
hinzu
ich rate euch auf jeden fall zu den
gesalzenen und gerösteten erdnüssen denn
die schmecken viel besser ich habe das
ganze auch mit umsatz in erdnüssen
ausprobiert und das ganze war dann viel
zu mächtig die massen lassen wir jetzt
etwa 15 minuten an der seite stehen und
machen mit unserem tortenboden weiter
den tortenboden gebe ich mir auf eine
schöne tortenplatte und lege da einen
regen drumherum damit wir das ganze
gleich ordentlich schichten können den
ohnehin schon super saftigen schoko
wohnen trinke ich jetzt noch mal mit
zuckersirup damit der geschmack noch
intensiver wird wie ich den hergestellt
habe das habe ich schon ein paar mal
gezeigt und schreibe es euch auch gerne
nochmal unten in die infobox
[Musik]
alternativ könnt ihr den boden auch mit
kakao trinken oder mit irgendeinem saft
ich finde allerdings dass der zucker
sirup einfach optimal hineinpasst
[Musik]
jetzt geben wir die noch warme karamell
masse auf den schoko boden und verteilen
sie gleichmäßig
[Musik]
unser karamell ist später nach dem
auskühlen übrigens nicht steinhart
sondern richtig schön weich und man kann
den kuchen richtig gut durchschneiden
nun muss die karamell schicht in den
kühlschrank damit sie vollständig
auskühlen kann und wir mit der nächsten
schicht weitermachen können
ich zeige euch allerdings schon mal die
zutaten für die nächste schicht das ist
an meinem beispiel auf love außerdem
welche mutter cremige erdnussbutter und
puderzucker für diesen schritt gebe ich
jetzt die folgenden zutaten meine
küchenmaschine einmal die weiche butter
die cremige erdnussbutter es gibt
nämlich auch diese kranke großmutter und
die brauchen wir nicht nimmt auf jeden
fall die cremige und außerdem noch den
puderzucker
das ganze lasse ich dann etwa zwei bis
drei minuten cremig aufschlagen
ihr könnt selbstverständlich auch euer
handrührgerät verwenden
[Musik]
nachdem alles cremig gerührt wurde geben
wir unser marshmallows live dazu dass
manchmal of life findet man ja
mittlerweile in gut sortierten
supermärkten schaute einfach mal in der
abteilung in der es auch marmelade zum
beispiel gibt oder in manchen
supermärkten ist es auch in der americas
ecke oder fragt am besten mal nach aber
ich bin mir sicher dass ihr auch einen
supermarkt in der nähe habt der dieses
mal schneller verkauft
[Musik]
nachdem sich dann alle zutaten gut
miteinander verbunden haben und das
macht läuft gut eingearbeitet wurde ist
die creme fertig
[Musik]
die erdnuss karamell schicht ist in der
zwischenzeit vollständig ausgekühlt und
das ist auch ganz wichtig denn ansonsten
würde jetzt die marshmallow kämen durch
die hitze schmelzen
[Musik]
die creme wird dann schön glatt
gestrichen und das funktioniert am
besten mit einer winkel palette
anschließend geben wir darüber dann
unseren zweiten schoko boden
[Musik]
damit wir den schokoladen boden jetzt
auch noch schön mit dem restlichen
zucker sirup trinken können habe ich
ihnen mit der schnitt seite nach oben
auf die themen gelegt
[Musik]
damit die creme jetzt auch noch mal
schön fest werden kann geben wir die
torte zugedeckt für mindestens zwei
stunden in den kühlschrank
anschließend bereiten mir den schuh
august zu und hierfür benötigen wir voll
mit kuvertüre und butter außerdem habe
ich für die deko noch sneakers und
erdnüsse beiseite gelegt für unser
wasserbad geben wir etwas wasser in
einem kochtopf lassen dass einmal
aufkochen schalten den herd dann aus und
lassen in einer separaten schüssel zwei
drittel der vollmilch kuvertüre in der
rest hitze des wassers schmelzen
nachdem dann alles vollständig
geschmolzen ist gehen wir die restliche
kuvertüre mit hinzu und lassen das dann
noch mal in der rest hitze der
schokolade schmelzen
[Musik]
zu guter letzt wird noch die butter mit
den zugegeben und auch unter rühren in
der schokolade geschmolzen und dann ist
unser guss auch schon fertig durch das
temperieren der kuvertüre hat sie jetzt
die perfekte konsistenz und einen
richtig schönen glanz
[Musik]
nun können wir unsere torte aus dem
tortenring befreien und hier gehe ich
ganz gerne noch mal mit einer palette an
den rand entlang damit auch nichts mehr
an klebt
[Musik]
jetzt geben wir den vorbereiteten
schokoladenguss auf die torte und
verteilen ihnen sowohl an der oberfläche
als auch am rand der torte
[Musik]
für die deko habe ich mir die erdnüsse
noch etwas feiner gehackt und gebe sie
an den unteren rand der torte solange
der schokoladenguss auch noch nicht fest
geworden ist kleben sie wie von alleine
[Musik]
für die oberfläche der torte schneide
ich mir meine minis niklas nochmal durch
drei und verteile sie dann auf der
oberfläche
ihr könnt selbstverständlich auch die
normal großen sneakers nehmen allerdings
finde ich dass die ministers
angeschnitten noch mal etwas süßes
aussehen aber ist natürlich auch wieder
vollkommen euch überlassen
[Musik]
für das letzte finish gebe ich jetzt
noch ganze erdnüsse zwischen die regel
und dann ist meine sticker scorte auch
schon fertig
[Musik]
bevor ihr sie serviert muss nur noch
ganz kurz der schokoladenguss an
trocknen und dann könnt ihr sie euch
endlich schmecken lassen
[Musik]
hier seht ihr die wundervolle sneakers
torte im anschnitt meiner meinung nach
eines der leckersten torten die ich je
gegessen habe
falls ihr auch solche sneakers fans seid
oder jemanden kennt der sneakers über
alles liebt dann habt ihr jetzt
folgendes zu tun
klappt die infobox auf macht euch ein
screenshot für den zutaten und lauf zum
supermarkt diese torte müsst ihr
probiert haben
[Musik]
falls ihr mir übrigens noch nicht auf
instagram folgt dann solltet ihr das
schnellstens nachholen denn dort erfahrt
ihr immer welches video als nächstes
kommt und ihr könnt mir dann auch gerne
vorschläge hinterlassen
weniger chance mein part heute bin ich
mal dran
sie stärken und zu arbeiten ich bekomme
so oft den ganzen tag alleine
so wie ihr geht jetzt direkt zu haben
dass familie ein paar stücke für meine
familie reserviert und der rest kam sie
arbeiten